معنا من امام محكمه العدل الدوليه في
لاهاي مراسل الجزيره محمد المدهون محمد
متى من المتوقع ان يصدر قرار من المحكمه
وما هي اتجاهات
الترجيحات نعم سلمى كل الانظار تتجه الى
قصر السلام مقر محكمه العدل الدوليه بعد
اقل من 90 دقيقه من الان ينتظر ان تخرج
رئيسه الهيئه القضائيه للمحكمه كي تبت
في طلب دوله جنوب افريقيا المقدمه في
الدعوه المرفوعه ضد دوله اسرائيل في
المرافعه الشفهيه قبل اسبوعين من الان كان
هناك طلب
تضمنته المذكره القانونيه التي قدمتها
جمهوريه جنوب افريقيا باتخاذ تدابير مؤقته
او اجراءات احترازيه طارئه او اجراءات
تحوطيه كل هذه الترجمات التي سنسمع
للمصطلح القانوني نفسه والذي يتخذ ط طبعا
هذه التدابير المؤقته للحمايه هي مخوله
للهيئه القضائيه في محكمه العدل الدوليه
تخول هذه الهيئه باتخاذها اذا رات ان حقوق
احد الاطراف في هذه الدعوه المرفوعه قد
تتضرر بشكل كبير وجسيم وبشكل لا يمكن
اصلاحه ونحن هنا نتحدث عن القتل والموت في
قطاع غزه هناك ناس يموتون لذلك فان هذه
الحجه الجنوب افريق
واقعه وهناك جمله من التدابير المؤقته
التي طلبتها جنوب افريقيا في مذكرتها
القانونيه لكن من المهم التاكيد مره اخرى
سلمى ان المحكمه اليوم لن تدين ولن تبرع
اسرائيل بشان التهم الموجهه اليها بعدم
امتثالها لالتزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه منع
الاباده الجماعيه والمعاقب عليها هذا مسار
طويل قد يستغرق سنوات وربما اكثر من عقد
من الزمان البوسنا عندما قدمت دواها ضد
يوغسلافيا عام
1993 انتظرت 14 عاما حتى عام 2007 كي تصدر
المحكمه حكمها القضائي النهائي في تلك
الدعوه ولكن يقول المراقبون المحامون
المختصون هنا ان الفريق القانوني لجنوب
افريقيا كانت لديه من الحصافه والدرايه
والعلم القانوني ما يكفي كي يضمنوا في
دعواهم هذا الطلب طلب التدابير الم مؤقته
ولعل هذه التدابير هي الاهم حقيقه بالنسبه
للناس الان في غزه لان هذه التدابير هي
لحمايه ارواح الناس وليس فقط لتحقيق
العداله للضحايا الذين سقطوا وقتلوا وهناك
انتظار كبير وا اذا ما قرنا هذه الحاله
بحالات مشابهه سابقه مثل حاله جامبيا
وميانمار
استغرقت المحكمه
72 يوما كي تصدر قرارها بشان التدابير
المؤقت انذاك في الحاله الثانيه المشابهه
حاله اوكرانيا وروسيا استغرقت المحكمه 19
يوما اليوم نتحدث فقط عن اسبوعين بعد
المرافعه الشفهيه لهذه الدعوه وهي فتره
قصيره جدا ربما هي الاخصر على الاطلاق في
اتخاذ هذه التدابير المؤقته وتعطي اشاره
من نوع ما باستشعار هؤلاء القضاه ال 15
بالحاجه الماسه والاستعجال لاتخاذ هذه
التدابير المؤ وهي قد تتراوح ما بين
المطالبه بوقف العمليات العسكريه وانهاء
هذه الحرب و وصولا الى ادخال المساعدات
ووقف التصريحات التحريضيه ننتظر الدقائق
القليله المقبله خلال الساعه والنصف
المقبلتين
بخصوص الاستماع لهذه
طبعا الحكم او القرار الامر القضائي من
محكمه العدل الدوليه بطبيعه الحال سنكون
في المتابعه شكرا لك حتى الساعه محمد
المدهون مراسلنا من امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه في هاي